Tên thật là nguyễn phụ vấn tuy, sinh ngày 2018, nâng 1828, là người quan xuy nhất của vụ hại đình và đón huy hóan thái hộ.
Nâng 1827, so kê vô hại định qua đời, vấn tuy kế vị, lấy ninh hiểu bảo đại, trở thành vỷ
vòa ngếp thứ huy bà của nha nguyễn trong lịch sự phong kiến Việt Nam. Tuy nhiên vô quan trụ nguyễn chỉ là buôn nhiên,
bởi được cũng thực dân pháp trả nướng như những viên trước đủ vía.
Hắn tám nămu nhìn chính trọng búm mấy làm, tào chào các mạng sục sôi khi thế là toàn rất nhiều tình thành chính cả nước, nhiều địa phương khởi nghĩa thành công sản chính quyền về tăng giân.
Ngày hai mai thằng tám nămu nhìn chính trọng búm làm, bờ đại nhận lượng bất định tiến từ 18 giân tập giải phóng với nội dông.
Chắc chỉ ở nguyết của tòàn thế gián chính quyền Nam, sẵn sàng hư dứt cả để tụi bán nền được là cuộc ra, chính tôi thủ kính xin lúc nế hay là một tự trị lịch xy, để tụi bỏ nghe tòm.
Chức có chào các mạng và nguyện phạc của giân, bào đại đại quy định một việc sẵn sút nhất của đợi ông chính là đồng ý khái vị. Ngày bán mấy thằng tám nămu nhìn chính trọng búm làm, bào đại đặc tríu khái vị, nhưng quyền điều kiện của giân lại trong hụt chính phủ dân chủ cộng hoài.
Trong thân khí nghiêm chăng, cơ quay li của chư đình hỏe được hạt xuống, cơ đào sau phạm được kéo lên.
Đại diện chính phủ kinh mạng lâm thời tuyên bố, soi bào chính thề con trụ ở hơi cũng như trên toàn bộ lãnh thổ Việt Nam,
và con bố chính sách quẩn nước Việt Nam sân trụ cập hoài.
Mục tiêu của kết mạng đặt ra là vừa khai gián đặc lập, hơi vừa khai đánh đồ, kể đồ phong kiến.
Thuy như vậy, thì đò răng là kết mạng, cẩn thám vở về, thì vừa là để thực hiện viết khác vòng đặc lập gián đặc vừa lãi bột,
chính vụ của bảo đài, tức là vì vô của quay cùng của tiêu nguyện, vô phải phải đi ở vế để mà tạo em kiếm lại.
Chúng cái này nó làm tạo lấy một cái bính giúp tiếp để của các mạng thẳng thám.
Dự kiện vô bảo đài vì vô của quay cùng của chỗ đại phong kiến nhạm nguyện khá vị,
mà nghe liệu xử vô của khủng tò lớn. Nó đã đặt dấu trở mê cho chế độ phong kiến tổ tại lưng người thế kiện,
một chi đợi lối thời, bột phải thuận theo sức mạng không thể chúng lại của nhân dân. Trong cuộc kinh mạng, mạng, mạng, ý chỉ của toàn xin tọng.